[Música]
vamos a ver la información relacionada
con los mercados y las principales
transacciones del día está con nosotros
en el estudio Jorge Hurtado Jorge
hablamos de los precios de producción
que aumentaron en Estados Unidos esto
Qué significa bueno Esto indica que la
demanda de las empresas y los
consumidores está siendo golpeada por la
subida de los tipos de interés pero
también que las cadenas de suministro se
están reparando tras meses de desorden
los servicios cayeron por primera vez en
casi dos años ofreciendo más prueba de
que la inflación esté empezando a ceder
lo que podría permitir a la reserva
Federal de Estados Unidos que es el
Banco Central de ese país disminuir su
agresivo ritmo de subida de los tipos de
interés los datos de la semana pasada
mostraron también que los precios al
consumo subieron menos de lo previsto en
octubre lo que sitúa el incremento anual
por debajo del 8% por primera vez en
ocho meses octubre es el segundo mes
consecutivo de caída de los precios del
comercio y el cuarto mes consecutivo de
caída de Los costos de almacenamiento
empresas de transporte como FedEx están
estacionando sus aviones debido a la
reducción de la demanda de los
consumidores y el descenso de los
precios al por mayor No necesariamente
es una buena noticia para los precios de
que los consumidores pagan en las
tiendas seguimos en Estados Unidos Jorge
porque dos senadores republicanos
solicitaron al gobierno de su país que
recurra al t-mec para revertir esa
decisión que ha tomado el presidente de
México Andrés Manuel López Obrador de
dejar de comprar maíz amarillo
transgénico a partir del 2024 bueno los
senadores advierten sobre las pérdidas
de miles de millones de dólares a
Estados Unidos precisamente por esta
decisión de del presidente mexicano
según ellos la propuesta del presidente
de México reduciría en un 90% las
exportaciones de maíz transgénico a
Estados Unidos en 2020 el presidente
López Obrador dijo que se impondría la
pausa la importación del maíz amarillo
genéticamente modificado y en octubre
Esto fue ratificado por el secretario de
una altura de Víctor Suárez según el
gobierno mexicano antes que termine el
año podríamos ver consultas de Estados
Unidos y Canadá sobre otro tema que es
crucial para el temec la política
energética de México se espera también
que esta semana comience En las
reuniones con representantes de México
Estados Unidos y Canadá para hacer estas
consultas nos vamos ahora hasta el Sur
del continente porque en Argentina hubo
un nuevo aumento en los precios al
consumidor ayayay bueno la inflación
anual ahí alcanzó el 88% es la mayor
tasa de las últimas tres décadas y se
encaminan a un alza acumulada de 100%
para cerrar este año según el Instituto
Nacional de estadísticas y censos el
índice de inflación de octubre fue de
6,3% En comparación con el mes anterior
superando la tasa del 6,2 que se
registró en septiembre y encadenando ya
cuatro meses consecutivos de subidas por
encima del 6% de inflación
intermenstrual Argentina y el fondo
monetario internacional corrigieron
también al alza las proyecciones de
inflación para 22 hasta un Rango de
entre el 90% y el 100% y para 2023 entre
el 55% y el 65% anual de inflación pero
los pronósticos privados que recaba el
Banco Central señalan que la inflación
será este año del 100% y el próximo año
en torno a un 90%. por eso entiendo no
porque el presidente Alberto Fernández
tiene un ataque de gastritis en la
Cumbre del g20 hablemos ahora de la
agencia internacional de energía que
aseguró sobre el impacto de un posible
nuevo embargo al crudo ruso bueno en su
informe mensual sobre el mercado del
petróleo la agencia señala que ese
embargo de parte de la Unión Europea que
entrará en vigor el 5 de diciembre para
las importaciones de crudo y el 6 de
febrero para los derivados añadirá mucha
más presión en los mercados se espera
que Rusia como país productor y
exportador estaría A Prueba con los
embargos de la Unión Europea que podrían
hacer caer su producción de petróleo por
debajo de los 10 millones de barriles
diarios el próximo tamaño es importante
decir que lo que deje de importar a la
Unión Europea no podría ser compensado
por mayores compras por ejemplo de sus
otros grandes compradores que son China
India o Turquía según el documento el
aumento de la demanda mundial de crudo
se va a frenar hasta 1,6 millones de
barriles diarios en 2023 frente a los
2,1 millones de este año debido a la
ralentización económica global el
elevado precio de los derivados del
petróleo y también la fortaleza del
dólar volvemos a Estados Unidos porque
los despidos de las grandes compañías
tecnológicas en ese país continúan
preocupando y dan mucho de qué hablar
Bueno y es que según un reporte de New
York Times Amazon estaría planeando
despedir a 10.000 empleados en medio del
temor de una recesión económica global y
es que esto llega tras la noticia de que
meta la empresa matriz de Facebook
anunció el despido de 11.000 empleados y
de que Twitter también haya despedido a
otros 3.700 y es que solo en los últimos
30 días con la alta inflación en la
subida de los tipos de interés las
principales empresas tecnológicas han
despedido a más de 23 mil personas en
total Amazon elevaría esa cifra a 33.000
personas otros que han despedido
personal son El fabricante de discos
duros seagate que despidió 3.200
empleados así como empresas como
Microsoft
stripe sailforce leaf pelotón y
dapperslab este año coinbase Snapchat y
shopify despidieron a unos mil empleados
cada uno empresas como Netflix de
despidió a 450 Robin Hood que es un
exchange de intercambio de criptomonedas
también despidió a una cuarta parte de
su personal y tesla la empresa otra de
las empresas de la humosa despidió a una
décima parte de su planilla según los
analistas se avecinan más recortes de
puestos de trabajo en el sector
tecnológico Muchas gracias Jorge por
este panorama general de la situación
económica a nivel mundial a continuación
en directo América ya viene el debate
sigan con nosotros